[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat bienvenue sur en Loire Atlantique
département qui fait partie de nos 1000
pays pour demain nous sommes précisément
à Nantes l'une des neuf métropoles
française labellisé frenchtech 7e ville
touristique du pays avec plus de 2
millions de visiteurs chaque année une
économie et une industrie directement
lié aux éléments naturels et tourné vers
la transition écologique pendant une
demi-heure on va découvrir ensemble ce
qui fait la valeur économique et humaine
de ce territoire ces entreprises
innovantes ces entrepreneurs audacieux
ces savoir faire uniquement des pépites
qui ont choisi de s'installer ici ou qui
sont nés sur ces terre et qui les
rendent très dynamiqu un élu va nous
accompagner pendant ce petit voyage il
va lui aussi découvrir et commenter ses
initiatives méconnues c'est un sénateur
qui vit sur ce territoire et qui pourra
apporter des réponses aux chefs
d'entreprise et peut-être les défendre à
la Chambre haute 1000 pays pour demain
c'est
parti bonjour ronand DC merci de nous
accueillir ici chez vous en Loire
Atlantique je précise que vous êtes
sénateur écologiste vice-président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
nous sommes ici à la Cité des congrès de
Nantes je crois que c'est un lieu
important qui participe au dynamisme de
la ville de Nantes c'est un lieu qui
vous parle aussi c'est un lieu dans
lequel vous avez des souvenirs c'est un
lieu dans lequel j'ai beaucoup de
souvenirs puisque j'ai une action locale
une action nationale mais aussi une
action internationale assez importante
et il se trouve que j'ai organisé ici de
de très grands événements euh des des
sommets sur le climat on a accueilli ici
tous les tous les grands élus du monde
en en 2013 pour eocity où on a passé
justement un message comme quoi on ne
peut pas résoudre les les grands enjeux
environnementaux sans la mobilisation
des gouvernements locaux on a réussi à
bouger les textes de négociation je
trouve que cet endroit est assez
symbolique et la Loire Atlantique dans
son ensemble là aussi dynamique riche
avec une industrie tournée vers la
transition écologique oui je je crois
qu'on est vraiment on est un département
qui va bien il faut le dire on n'est pas
très loin du plein emploi ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on a pas aussi évidemment
des des difficultés et c'est
effectivement un département qui a
réussi à maintenir son industrie comment
vous expliquez qu'il a si bien ce
département il attire il attire beaucoup
il attire énormément il attire
énormément pour deux raisons pour une
qualité de vie euh qui tient à la fois
de la proximité de la mer c'est un
département extrêmement actif dynamique
sur le plan culturel non est une ville
euh là-dessus qui qui produit
aujourd'hui beaucoup de de de grands
événements de grandes expositions c'est
cétait la c'est la ville de de Royal del
luux c'est c'est c'est la ville des des
allumés pour reprendre un peu l'histoire
et donc finalement tout ce cocktail fait
que aujourd'hui ceux qui ont les moyens
de choisir l'endroit où ils vont
travailler ont tendance effectivement à
choisir des territoires comme les ntres
qui aussi nous posent des difficultés
alors il vaut mieux être un territoire
en développement qu'un territoire qui s
c'est évident mais derrière sur le
logement l'accès au logement euh pour
les les ménages modestes l'étalement
urbain que ça sous-entend on a aussi
toutes ces difficultés aujourd'hui en
l'URE Atlantique Renaud DC l'une des
promesses de cette émission c'est de
faire découvrir quelques entreprises du
coin celles qui se démarque par leur
histoire par leur originalité on va
commencer notre tour d'horizon chez un
fabricant de couteau pas comme les
autres sa matière première il va la
chercher dans un marais celui de la
Brière que vous connaissez sûrement et
cette matière première c'est le mortta
un bois très précieux le fondateur de
l'entreprise en parle très bien il
s'appelle Jean-Henry Pagnon je vous
laisse le
découvrir
[Musique]
ce petit bouquin c'est une lecture 15
ans en arrièree duquel j'ai découvert
l'existence du Mor le maire de saintjin
ne sortait jamais de chez lui sans sa
précieuse CAN en
[Musique]
Mor j'étais littéralement transporté
j'ai trouvé que un bois purement local
au bilan carbone exceptionnel c'était
vraiment le matériau essentiel pour
fabriquer l'objet d'une vie c'est-à-dire
le
couteau ces marais ici il y a 5000 an
n'existait pas c'était juste une grande
forêt de chaîne et quand les arbres sont
tombés au lieu d'être abandonnés à leur
sort ils se sont enfoncés dans la tourbe
la tourbe les a recouvert elle fait
comme une sorte de sarcophage naturel le
bois s'est minéralisé il s'est chargé en
silce il s'est admirablement conservé et
c'est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
mort ici on est complètement recouvert
par les EAU plus on va avancer dans le
temps plus le niveau d'eau va augmenter
et puis en septembre et en octobre quand
nous allons extraire et bien c'est
complètement asséché il ne reste que les
[Musique]
canaux allez à
l'atelierok et
voilà là c'est le trésor le mortard oh
là là là làe-moi
ça ça c'est exceptionnel
ça ce qui m'a amené à changer de métier
c'est simplement que je me sentais pas à
ma place dans l'ancienne entreprise qui
m'employait c'était une multinationale
260000 salariés dans le monde c'est un
truc absolument gigantesque j'avais pas
un sentiment de liberté dans dans mon
exercice alors qu'ici je fais très
exactement ce que je
veux allez les gars on se pousse ouais
ouais ouais quoi j'ai pas choisi
d'implanter mon entreprise ici je me
suis implanté personnellement ici
puisque ma maison est en face et par
nature c'est ici que j'ai démarré mon
activité il y a maintenant 13 ans en
arrière vous voyez ce Couto et bien tout
démarre en TER de fabrication sur cette
vieille machine des années
50 on doit couper le Mortin pour obtenir
une côte aux dimensions
parfaites et voilà ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une sûr donc il y a une face qui
est réalisée maintenant il va falloir
faire la deième
pass le travail d'artisan coutelier ça
nécessite d'avoir quelques connaissances
en métallurgie en mécanique en
ébénisterie c'est une somme de plusieurs
compétences faire un couteau ça
nécessite également de faire preuve de
beaucoup de finesse et de beaucoup de
précision si on a un couteau qui crante
qui qui crante mal c'est un couteau raté
si on a un couteau qui offre un mauvais
retour c'est un couteau raté si on a un
couteau qui n'est pas dans l'axe c'est
un couteau
raté un humble couteau comme celui qui
est en train de monter Rodin a nécessité
près de 1 an de travail et de
développement heureusement il a du
succès mais il faut imaginer le le la
prise de risque que d'investir un an de
travail pour un produit dont on n'est
pas sûr de la rencontre avec son
public un projet entrepreneurial c'est
une vie
difficulté faut pas rêver c'est toujours
difficile et comme le dit ma femme te
plains pas toi ça marche imagine ce pour
qui ça ne marche pas donc oui ça marche
mais c'est une galère au quotidien faut
faut être un peu Mazo je crois pour
faire ce métier c'est-à-dire par exemple
il y a 2 ans nous avons été invités par
l'Institut national de la propriété
intellectuelle à déposer un dossier
d'indication géographique ce qui va nous
permettre de de protéger le morta dans
son territoire c'estàdire la Brière et
puis après 2 ans de travail et bien
notre dossier a été retoqué en raison
d'un d'un d'un d'un obscur petit article
interne à l'INPI et qui n'est pas
conforme à la réglementation européenne
il a fallu envoyer une cinquantaine de
lettres à des députés à des sénateurs à
à des cabinets ministériel on se sent
bien souvent seul dans ce genre de
situation voilà une belle histoire on
vient de l'entendre mais pas un long
fleuve tranquille hein on entend bien
aussi les difficultés de ce chef
d'entreprise euh on a aussi entendu
Emmanuel Macron récemment par parler
d'une simplification est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire d'urgent pour ces
chefs d'entreprise alors je pense que
depuis la nuit des temps les chefs
d'entreprisees considèrent euh qu'il y a
trop de
paperass j'ai eu moi-même une petite
entreprise culturelle donc je je sais
effectivement
l'URSAF euh le bilan de fin d'année euh
donc effectivement il y a une partie
administrative moi moi je retourne
presque les choses euh il est quand même
très intéressé par l'INP parce que ça va
protéger son métier sa marque je sais
pas pour un morta asiatique demain en
chimie de synthèse donc donc le fait
d'avoir finalement des cadres
administratifs très fort c'est aussi ce
qui distingue un grand pays développé
d'un pays en développement et souvent
d'un pays moins riche par contre je
pense qu'on a un problème qui est que la
norme ne peut pas tout prévoir et qu' a
obligatoirement toujours un ici là où ça
rentre pas dans le cadre de la norme et
qui nous manque probablement un lieu et
je l'avais proposé même lors des
dernières élections sénatorial un lieu
de régulation où les cas non prévus
finalement puisse les discuter peut-être
d'ailleurs avec les parlementaires
puisque j'ai bien vu qu'il avait fait
appel au parlementairire pour régler son
problème ce qui prouve que les sénateurs
servent à quelque chose puisqu'on les
appelle mais mais qu'effectivement il n
peut-être un maillon mais les pays qui
ont peu de normes qui ont d'encadrement
administratif sont des pays moins riches
et lui-même a besoin de cette protection
par rapport à son propre métier il y a
aussi quelque chose inéressant dans
l'expérience de Jean-Henri Pagnon c'est
qu'il nous explique qu'il a quitté une
grande entreprise pour lancer sa propre
entreprise il a quitté une multinational
ça veut dire qu'il a pris des risques et
ça aussi j'ai envie de le retenir pour
me dire que c'est possible en France et
qu'on peut le dire à nos téléspectateur
c'est possible bah c'est non seulement
possible mais beaucoup en rêv parce que
être son propre propre chef d'entreprise
être artisan
être être dans la culture c'est être
c'est une liberté d'ailleurs lui-même ne
se plaint pas enfin il se plaint de
manière secondaire mais il est quand
même extrêmement heureux puisqu'il a
préféré ça à la hiérarchie d'un d'un
grand groupe il a fait son choix alors
on va continuer notre petit tour
d'horizon des entreprises en Loire
Atlantique on va maintenant faire la
connaissance de Simon Müller il a 39 ans
il est maître verrier comprenait
sousffleur de verre il y a 12 ans il a
créé son propre atelier lié à Vertou
dans le sud de Nantes et sa petite
particularité c'est qu'il ne travaille
pas pour les chaînes de magasin de déco
ni pour la grande distribution non lui
il a fait un choix plus original mais
plus risqué aussi
regardez un jour un collègue avec qui je
bossais avait un petit atelier de verre
et j'ai essayé une fois et j'ai été
complètement piqué et absorbé par cette
matière et puis j'avais encore l'âge de
pouvoir me poser cette question de ma
reconversion le moment de la fabrication
devient un moment plutôt instinctif où
là il y a une sorte d'érance un peu
psychologique et ça
devient vraiment de l'intelligence de la
main en fait c'est un truc de de tempo
c'est comme une
danse il y a jamais de temps mort c'est
vraiment un métier il y a pas de pause
pour reprendre ses esprits en fait on
peut avoir des pièces qui vont durer
jusqu'à 3 4 heures de production donc tu
es vraiment assez focus pendant
plusieurs
heures nous on est vraiment sur cette
production niche de sur-mesure on répond
au monde du luxe on répond aux artistes
du milieu de l'art contemporain on
répond au designers c'est qu'on va
vraiment se placer entre une pièce et
une pièce et 500 pièces quoi voilà il
est là notre
marché commence à souffler un peu Clara
léger s'il te
plaît vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y stop
le soufflage c'est vraiment un travail
de binôme en soit on peut pas vraiment
travailler seul hein on est toujours
accompagné on a un fonctionnement un peu
de cuisine dans le sens où tu as un chef
qui va coordonner toutes ses petites
mains il va avoir son premier qui est
vraiment son son jeune le mieux formé le
plus proche de lui et après on va avoir
les comis donc sur des ouvertures de
portes la protection aider à mesurer les
pièces avec les
compas je suis d'une famille
d'indépendants donc on a tous un peu ça
dans le sang le le montage de projet et
on a démarré dans l'Est de la France du
coup en louant les ateliers de notre
école et Nant plusieurs années de suite
nous ont fait des beaux contrats et on
est venu en fait en visite dans cette
vue de s'installer ENF dans nos propres
locaux la ville nous a soutenu aussi
dans notre installation he donc dans nos
recherches
d'ateliers voilà on a senti une sorte de
d'effervessence assez dynamique et assez
accueillante pour prendre cette décision
là
[Musique]
je pense qu'on doit être dans un effort
collectif sur ces questions là de
réinventer un artisanat de le reramener
dans les centres-villees il y a quelque
chose aussi sur ces questions là en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on a envie que nos enfants
il voient demain quoi est-ce que
finalement les vendeurs de téléphone et
les épiceries de nuit c'est c'est ça le
modèle économique qu'on avait envie de
présenter à nos enfants
quoi stop c'est bon pour
moi donc c'est vraiment la question de
la valorisation du métier et de la place
qu'on prend dans la société et qui bien
sûr est aussi une
revalorisation de salaire he parce qu'on
a des métiers qui sont durs qui doivent
être revaloriser et une vraie question
de revalorisation en terme d'image quoi
on a vu pendant le covid hein on a
remercié nos infirmiers nonani nonana
voilà mais ça peut s'étendre encore un
peu plus hein remercions nos artisan de
manière
large alors Simon Müller au N d'ontec il
nous parle surtout de la revalorisation
de l'image des artisans est-ce qu'il a
raison est-ce qu'on a un problème avec
l'image de l'artisanat en France moi je
trouve pas que que l'artisanat est
dévalorisé puis là c'est l'artisanat
d'art euh et moi j'aié été extrêmement
intéressé par par ce reportage y compris
son choix de l'agglomération dantaise ce
que je disais en début d'émission on est
sur un territoire attractif riche euh et
où il a une clientèle puisque il décide
effectivement de ne pas passer par un un
un distributeur donc je pense que ce
type d'artisanat aujourd'hui correspond
à une société où il y a du pouvoir
d'achat où il y a une classe moyenne
supérieur installé qui a un vrai pouvoir
d'achat et ça n'est pas pour rien s'il
rejoint nante puisque lui-même a fait le
choix de quitter l'est de la France pour
venir chez nous parce que chez nous ici
en Loir atlantique il y a une clientèle
voulez dire que c'est tellement
attractif que ça se fait au détriment
des autres départements on gagne quand
même 15000 habitants par an parce que
effectivement on est devenu un
territoire extrêmement attractif et je
trouve que ce reportage montre cette
attractivité Simon Müller parle aussi de
la formation on sent que la formation
est en question dans ce reportage avec
un cap qui est passé à 1 an maintenant
on peut passer un CAP en 1 an ce qui
paraît ASSP parce que c'est pas une
manière là aussi de dévaloris les
métiers manuel moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec lui pour dire il faut
revaloriser le geste c'est effectivement
important de dire il y a pas que ceux
qui ont fait bac + 12 qui ont une place
et une légitimité dans la société celui
qui connaît les gestes participe aussi
de la richesse collective donc ça mais
ça c'est un problème quand même assez
ancien et structurant en France j'ai le
sentiment quand même que l'artisanat d'
qui est le son
secteur n'est pas lui dévalorisé mais
effectivement et ça c'est un vrai sujet
pour nous en l' Atlantique on a beaucoup
d'emplois à pourvoir dans le domaine de
la construction notamment métallurgique
on a les emplois de la construction on
manque aussi d'emploi et il faut
effectivement que dans notre discours
collectif on valorise ceux qui
construisent les maisons comme ceux qui
envisagent l'intelligence artificiel ou
les les programmes informatiques on a un
petit rituel dans cette émission Ronal
c'est l'entreprise coup de cœur on
demande demande à l'élu de nous parler
d'une entreprise à laquelle il tient en
particulier c'est le moment peut-être de
détailler la CTI hein je crois en Loire
Atlantique on a des entreprises qui sont
justement dans cette dynamique là CTI en
fait partie le siège est à maschkou donc
aujourd'hui ils produisent du panneau
photovoltaïque par rapport au discours
un peu convenu que j'entends y compris
dans l'hémicycle au Sénat comme quoi on
exporte tous nos panneaux
photovoltaïques bah non on en construit
en Loire Atlantique c'est des milliers
d'emplois aujourd'hui je trouve que ces
entreprises sont essentielles surtout ce
sont des entreprises à mission et que
cétit notamment mais une part
extrêmement importante de son bénéfice
sur une fondation et notamment sur
l'accompagnement de la formation de ceux
qui sont les moins qualifiés donc ça
reboucle totalement avec le sujet
précédent un nouveau reportage Renand
dtech une nouvelle entreprise elle a été
fondée par un tout jeune ingénieur qui
travaillait dans l'aéronautique mais qui
a tout plaqué pour être en phase avec
ses valeurs pour mettre son savoir au
service de la planète de l'écologie de
la sobriété énergétique il a décidé de
fabriquer des objets durables à base de
matériaux recyclés je suis sûr que ça va
vous plaire Renand DC on le rejoint à
saintnazer je m'appelle Paul mourise je
suis fondateur de l'avant d'après donc
l'avant d'après c'est une entreprise qui
développe un mode de vie plus sobre par
le biais des objets basse technologie
comme cette super marmite norvégienne
c'est un compartiment isolant qui permet
de terminer la cuisson des aliments en
mettant 10 15 minutes à chauffer la
casserole voir 20 minutes pour les
grosses casseroles mais derrière on peut
aller de 6 à 8 he de cuisson donc en
fait ça sont des plat mis jetés sur des
plats longue durée ça permet de faire
une centaine d'euros d'économie par an
sur l'énergie des plaques de
cuisson au lieu de réfléchir
classiquement ok je vais à Brico truc à
Casto truc et et je j'achète de manière
classique la matière mais là plutôt Ben
qui jette ces matières où est-ce que je
peux les récupérer en effet c'est euh
ben penser différemment c'est euh
vachement plus dur et euh mais bon c'est
comme ça aussi qu'on change les choses
un peu à son échelle
quoi voilà un avion qui transporte
d'autres avions bienvenue à saintazer
contribuer à ce genre de projet euh
faire des avions toujours plus toujours
plus gros toujours plus vite toujours
plus loin ça avait aucun sens pour moi
et du coup ben je me suis lancé euh pour
faire cours dans l'entrepreneuriat des
des low tech quelque chose qui a
vachement plus de sens pour moi quoi ça
c'est des chutes euh de grosses caisses
pour l'industrie qui s'en débarrasse et
du coup ben moi je les récupère pour
après euh faire pour que ça serve de
matière
première là on est à saintnazer en Loire
Atlantique alors j'ai choisi de faire
mon activité ici parce que c'est un
bassin industriel et donc il y a c'est
un terrain de jeu pour récupérer des
déchets et aussi bah parce que j'ai vécu
une bonne partie de mon enfant de siile
[Musique]
là on récupère du bois il y a il y a
plein de trucs qui vont pas ça se trouve
c'est pas la bonne taille l'épaisseur
varie ENF voilà il y a plein de défauts
donc c'est vrai qu'on paye pas
directement la matière mais il y a plus
de travail derrière donc au final bah
sur le prix du produit on gagne on gagne
quand même un peu mais pas tant que ça
quoi donc c'est vraiment un choix de
faire de de prendre ce temps pour aller
chercher ces matériaux faire des des
partenariats avec les entreprises pour
pour récupérer ces matières qui enfin
c'est fou de jeter ça
quoi j'essaie d'être le plus positif
possible sur le produit donc en effet il
y a la partie économie circulaire avec
la récupération des matériaux il y a
l'économie social et solidaire avec un
NAT donc des travailleurs handicapés
donc en fait la partie en bois elle est
faite
elle est découpée assemblée par un NAT
puis moi je fais la caisse en aluminium
à l'intérieur hop
là c'est des plaques d'imprimerie en
fait une fois qu'elles ont servies elles
sont recyclé moi ça me permet de faire
toute la partie intérieure de la marmite
qu'on
voità ça renvoie le rayonnement vers la
casserole et ça permet de maintenir un
peu plus la chaleur à l'intérieur de la
la
marvgienne mon métier est à encourager
et à développer parce qu'il est très
vertueux économie d'énergie économie
d'eau réduction des déchets l'idée c'est
vraiment de laisser tomber les gros
métiers d'ingénieur pour pour aller vers
quelque chose plus au énergie le vivant
la biodiversité la pollution tellement
de choses à faire que de fabriquer des
moteurs d'avion que de fabriquer des
routes que de fabriquer
des
foncé r ce qui est beau dans ce
reportage c'est de voir aussi cette
jeunesse très motivée et qui met son
travail et son savoir-faire au service
de la planète de l'écologie ça rend
optimiste quand même oui ça rend
optimiste mais je je trouve
qu'effectivement son son choix c'est
aussi un peu un un un signal et et un
cri sur le fait de dire le travail c'est
c'est un sens il faut que le travail a
un sens et là effectivement il pose un
acte et vous en voyez d'autres autour de
vous voyez cette jeunesse évoluer tendre
vers cela ah ben je crois que on en a
beaucoup d'exemples aujourd'hui encore
récemment à Polytechnique mais on a vu
ça à gros parch des des jeunes très
diplômés qui disent j'irais pas
travailler dans des
entreprises qui n'ont pas intégré leur
rôle dans la transition mais on sent que
c'est moins confortable pour eux ce sont
aussi pas forcément des CDI c'est de la
création d'entreprise c'est plus
difficile
c'est tendance comment faire en sorte
que la création d'entreprise quelle
qu'elle soit qu'on soit dans la marmine
Norvégienne dans l'artisan d'Ar ou dans
le couteau euh c'est c'est par
définition une prise de risque mais
c'est la liberté de la prise de risque
son action elle elle économise des
tonnes de CO2 parce que là on est
vraiment au cœur de l'efficacité
énergétique donc donc c'est un
cheminement totalement cohérent de de sa
part mais moi je n'oppose pas euh ceux
qui finalement posent des actes assez
forts comme lui en disant je sors du
système puisque c'est ça je sors du
système et ceux qui rest et ceux qui
restent pour faire aussi
mod les les les grands process
industriels on a besoin aussi que que le
le monde économique sorte effectivement
d' d'un d'un système conventionnel donc
ce qui veut dire que on on a aussi des
entreprises qui ne jouent toujours pas
le jeu et c'est quand même une grosse
difficulté aujourd'hui on arrive à la
fin de cette émission Ronal anch un
dernier petit rituel avant de se quitter
trois bonnes raisons de venir
s'implanter en Loire Atlantique il y a
énormément de bonnes raisons de venir en
l' Atlantique vous Diraz c'est un
département extraordinairement agréable
à vivre euh avec beaucoup de nature
c'est très beau il y a un dynamisme
culturel une capacité de projet commun
très important une capacité de
résistance aussi c'est ici quand même
qu'un grand projet d'infrastructure n'a
pas vu le jour à l'aéroport NotreDame
des Landes avec des gens qui
travaillaient ensemble en semaine et qui
allaient manifester les uns contre les
autres le le dimanche c'est très très
particulier c'est la Bretagne aussi
c'est fondamentalement un département
breton culturellement dans à ce
niveau-là donc c'est c'est un
département de projet commun on parle
souvent du jeu à la nantesse pour le FC
Nantes mais c'est vrai que c'est un
département où où les les uns et les
autres savent travailler ensemble donc
on est effectivement dans une terre
extrêmement ouverte qui accueille mais
qui du coup à sèche parfois aussi
d'autres territoires donc avant de venir
il faut aussi se demander si finalement
on n'est pas plus utile là où on est
merci Ron de nous avoir fait découvrir
la Loire Atlantique merci de nous avoir
accueilli merci aussi aux chefs
d'entreprisees qui nous ont accueilli
dans leurs entreprises et merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi sur Public Sénat à
très bientôt
[Musique]
merci